today i'm announcing that we're forming
a new organization
the national institute for health
protection
the national institute for health
protection will have a
single and relentless mission
protecting people from external threats
to this country's health external
threats like biological weapons
pandemics and of course infectious
diseases
of all kinds it will combine our
world-class
talent and science infrastructure with
the growing response capability of nhs
test and trace
and the sophisticated analytical
capability that we're building in the
joint biosecurity
center of course these institutions work
incredibly closely
already to get today but i want that
integration to be seamless
crucially this will be a national
institute that
works very much locally
working with local directors of public
health and their teams
who are in my opinion the unsung heroes
of health protection
their local insight and intelligence is
a mission-critical part of our response
the national institute for health
protection will also work closely with
the devolved administrations
taking on existing uk-wide
responsibilities
and supporting all four chief medical
officers with access to the best
scientific
and analytical advice by bringing these
parts of the system together
we can get more than the sum of the
parts
and the mission that mission is for a
purpose
so we have a stronger more joined up
response to protect people and the
communities
in which they live